Eric is with us Eric's and Idaho how are
you Eric
I'm doing well Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up good
pleasure to visit with you my wife and I
have been debt-free other than our home
for the past 12 years because of the
principle GP until we really appreciate
that I not only got my bachelor's degree
but also my master's degree while
supporting a family of seven people
total good for you without having to do
any student loans because of the
principles you teach so it works cool
but so I got my nurse practitioner
degree in license last year and this
last summer my wife and I spontaneously
well kind of [ __ ] a yes we bought a
camp trailer in a pickup truck to go
along with it to tell it we had to
borrow some money to do that and the
question is our goals we want to get it
paid off by the end of this next year so
by the end of 2020 we're able to do
about two and a half times what the
payments the minimum payments are but my
question is do we do we tackle it full
force and turn it up a notch and and
take the money that we're putting 50
percent of our income that we're putting
into our retirement do we stop doing
that and put it towards the debt to get
that paid off and then go back to saving
for retirement or do we just kind of
plug along with what we're doing now
well I don't know you won't work our
plan or yours that's true and I and I
had a feeling you would say that no this
is this is straight-up stupid dude I
mean that was just dumb yeah you worked
all this time you did all these
wonderful things you pulled them all off
and and then you just go
and cow stuff up to your knees I got
that da Qaeda that you talked about yeah
and then some so you know I if you want
to apply our principles to this process
which you would go back to baby step two
so you would stop all retirement you'd
clean out all savings down to a thousand
dollars and you would apply to the
stupid camper right yeah
and once then then you apply everything
out of your life no vacations no eating
out your back on beans and rice your
back on baby step to you you regressed
you regressed all the way back I mean
this is do not pass go do not collect
$200 go straight to jail right this is
the penalty step in the game and so yeah
you just step back if you're gonna do
our stuff I mean but I you know you know
the problem was you fell into the trap
of saying I can afford it very much yes
you forgot that you can never afford
that so anyway the you know III other
than possibly just selling this crap I
guess I would just go back to baby step
to clean that stop all retirement stop
everything and clean out any money you
have in savings down to a thousand
dollars and no vacations and no eating
out until you get this done and work
overtime and beans and rice rice and
beans and scorched earth on the
lifestyle and an attack again I somehow
don't believe you would do that so I
don't know what to tell you because I
think you are under the illusion you can
afford this and you're just gonna Diddy
Bop along with it so I don't know I'm
I'm sad for you I really am